still so heartbreaking to watch Celine
Dion saying her final goodbyes to her
husband Rene Angelil and this week marks
the three or anniversary of his funeral
which was broadcast live in Canada and
streamed at stateside now currently
Celine is in France for a Paris Fashion
Week where a sweet reminder of their
love brought Celine to tears an
emotional Celine wiped away a tear in
the front row of Valentin of show at
Paris Fashion Week fans have pointed out
that Celine and Renee's wedding song the
first time ever I saw your face is
playing in the background
[Music]
ever
[Music]
not only dis alene record that song and
her 2004 album miracle she has also
performed it live many times on Tuesday
the three-year anniversary of Renee's
funeral Celine arrived to Alexander
Botti a show and a black trenchcoat the
50 year old transformed the stairs into
a concrete catwalk showcasing a sexy
thigh-high slit in her dress underneath
inside Selena gave OTA a standing
ovation at the end of the show and
during her four days in Paris Celine has
proven herself to be one of the most
passionate spectators at Fashion Week in
2016 she told the ety the city of love
has that effect on ER that the world
especially in DM you know in Paris is
offering so much it's just to have a
good times play you know you wearing
jeans is as much fun as a long gown Wow
looks so good
Angie Wow you next month Selene will
begin the final run off her Las Vegas
residency inside the Colosseum at
Caesars Palace her final show is on June
the 8th
[Music]